en france alors que certains de ses
voisins européens commencent à alizée
allait alléger les restrictions le pass
vaccinale lui entre en vigueur à partir
d'aujourd'hui pour aller au restaurant
ou dans un centre commercial il faudra
présenter un schéma vaccinal complet un
test négatif ne suffit plus pour les non
vaccinés voyez les précisions tout de
suite de notre reporter et c'est el farj
[Musique]
bonjour estelle lepage vaccinale qui
entrent donc en vigueur aujourd'hui en
france concrètement qu'est ce qui va
changer
rien c'est désormais officiel à magali
pour aller au restaurant au musée ou
encore pour prendre le train il vous
faudra désormais présenter votre pass
vaccinale il remplace tout simplement le
passé sanitaires que nous avons connue
ces derniers mois pour avoir se passe un
test négatif n'est plus valable il faut
pouvoir justifier d'un schéma vaccinal
complet noter qu'à partir du 15 février
il vous faudra un rappel c'est donc la
troisième dose quatre mois après la
dernière injection pour accéder aux
lieux où le pass sanitaires étaient
demandés tout lé français désormais à
partir de 16 ans vont donc devoir
présenter leur pack sinal et pour la
suite estelle il ya des raisons d'être
optimiste en tout cas c'est ce qu'a
indiqué ce week-end le porte-parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent
oui exactement à gabriel attal qui s'est
déclaré me rassure east mis en ferme
east mais tout simplement
réalistes face à la situation ainsi
sanitaire que connaît le pays il n'y a
cependant pas de décrue global de
l'épidémie at il prévenu en france 350
mille cas de kovy 19 sont détectés à
chaque jour en ce moment mais il y a un
début de baisse dans les services de
réanimation une baisse qui pour le porte
parole du gouvernement s'explique par la
diminution du variant est delta du côté
d'eau mikron s'il progresse au niveau
national ils baissent dans les
territoires où il est apparu le plus tôt
des raisons donc d'être optimiste pour
le porte parole du gouvernement merci
beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
précisions et on va suivre évidemment la
mise en place de ce pass vaccinale dans
nos prochaines éditions